>>Well, I've been asked to make a statement
here in Davos, which is a
very interesting place, where you meet all
kinds of different
personalities and people.
And even though I'm in politics, I was thinking
I might say a few words
about innovation and how I see it concerning,
particularly, technology,
but I also see that as a political dimension.
We are facing in the world so many major challenges.
I would say that the younger generation today
is facing the biggest
challenges humankind has ever faced in the
past in its history.
And in order to deal with this, we need to
work together.
We need to pool our forces, whether it's climate
change, financial
crisis, on poverty and inequality, whether
it's on issues of migration
and multicultural societies we're living in,
but we also need to find
innovative solutions.
Innovation from technical solutions, innovations
in politics itself, in
how we deliberate, how we work, how we use
issues, platforms like web
tools to have interactive democratic, participative
types of solutions.
But, um, how we create environment of innovation,
an environment of
innovation is not simply chaos.
It is creating the necessary platforms.
I'll take the example, which I think most
people know, is the iPhone
where you see there is a specific platform.
However, this huge innovation with all the
apps that have been
developed over the last year or two.
So you have a surge of innovation but you
also have a very secure
environment.
So if you transfer that to politics, that
would mean creating societies
with a secure environment where people can
feel secure, secure enough
to take risks to be innovative, to take initiatives.
And that means that we politicians have to
create that environment of
security, of -- of quality, if you like, of
good education, good health
services, and also freedom to take initiative.
I would say, of course, that looking at what's
going on, what is
fascinating for me is how we bring innovation
to an area which we don't
too much innovation, which is education.
And now with these new gadgets, new books,
the Kindles, the iPad, and
so on, I believe we're moving to an area where
the book will become
much more electronic, much more interactive.
Where you could have a virtual school, cyber-school
if you like, and
people could all have the information that
they want through the 'net,
through the Internet.
But also be very interactive.
And the classroom changing from a sort of
hierarchal structure to much
more of a gathering, where you share the experiences
and your projects
you've already developed and the communications
you've had on the 'net
with -- in a live way, in a live group -- much
more, I would say
democratic, much more collective, much more
human.
So in fact technology can bring a much more
humane type of school and
schooling and much more particibility for
all and much more
personalized development of information and
education processes from
the richer countries to the more -- to the
poorer countries and
developing countries.
Give access to this common wealth, if you
like, which is, we are
creating more and more, which is this common
knowledge of humanity
which has to be accessible to all.